hey there et Canada at Serena Ryder on  my set for my video ice age couldn't  change  Asian  ah blows it's arenas third single off  for album utopia and it has you're being  a bit introspective well the funny thing  about this song is that it's actually  about the relationship that I have with  myself and the different parts of myself  we've been having a great time like it  was so fun being at the seniors home and  hanging out and having a dance party  with everybody and just the concept of  you know watching somebody who's who's  been shut down for so long come alive  inside and by listening to a song you  know it's spawns firing it's like  anything's possible and you know when  you have that sense of hope and joy  inside of yourself the power of music  can do anything